Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is radiolab, the podcast, the homecoming podcast.
Actually welcome. One of the things that Robert and I had in common when we met,
way back when was that we both went to Oberlin, Oberlin college in Ohio.
I did music as a composition major and this was in the 90s Robert studied
history in the a sepia colored sixties at least in my mind.
And despite our difference in ages,
we both left this school feeling like Oberlin was a really big part of who we
are.
So when we were asked to return to Oberland to speak on campus on March six 2008
as part of their convocation series,
we were totally thrilled and nervous and terrified and thrilled. Anyhow,
it was a snow covered night and we went into Finny Chapel.
All right. Finny Chapel. Those words mean nothing to you.
But to us Feeney chapel is like Madison Square Garden because this was,
you know,
this is where you went to see jazz greats play and you heard speeches by
cultural dignitaries. But there we were, these two schmoes onstage talking,
you know, to our old professors and it was really quite weird frankly.
So anyways, we did a whole long lecture,
which got into lots of Oberland Nostalgia and we're going to spare you most of
that.
But I'm going to play you just a couple excerpts from the evening where we tell
stories about Radiolab that you may not have heard before to get started.
Here is the Robert and Jad Romance Story. Well,
not really a story of how we met,
which centers around the first radio piece that we ever made together.
I'm going to play that for you. Never before heard Radiolab piece.
Prepare yourself. This is Radiolab. The early years.
So five years ago I was working at w NYC.
I was sort of radio lab was not yet a thing. Um,
I was between jobs so to speak.
And someone hands me the program director hands me a stack of scripts and says,
go interview these people. And I did.
And at the very end of the stack was a guy named Robert Crow,
which I sort of knew the name a little bit.
And uh, he said, you, what's your story before we do any of this?
What's your story? I said, well, I work at m w NYC and I freelance for NPR.
We don't, he said, me too. And I said, when he asked me,
well what about before that? I said, well, I work at WBAI.
We do, you do. And then he said,
where did you go to school when I said Oberlin and yeah, that
and uh, I said like, what? So, so this is the deal.
Like you're like living my life 25 years after me.
Let's go have breakfast and you can tell me what it's like on the other side or
whatever you call it. And uh, somewhere.
And like breakfast number of 31,
we decided that we would try some radio together.
We started doing various weird oddly strange experiments that, um,
few of which have survived,
but we do have the very first thing we collaborated on,
which we thought was like fabulous.
We thought this is going to be the beginning of a revolution. And uh,
in a small way, small way.
The phone call we got was from IRA glass who runs this American life was a
friend of mine. But he's also like, you know the god. So he says, Hey,
we going to have a show coming up.
It's an hour show but it will only have two minute contributions.
So you had this record or something? Yes.
So the show that IRA was planning on airing was flag day.
That was the projected broadcast day.
I happened to have purely coincidentally a piece of archival tape and someone
had sent me,
which was a 1950s picture book audio that described the rules,
which you are supposed to approach the flag.
You are supposed to salute the flag,
how you're supposed to display the flag when there are other flags in the room.
All kinds of very arcane, um,
my new shit about how to respect the flag and it's completely ridiculous.
Totally. And here's what we did. Here's what we did
a few weeks ago.
My friend Jad got a tape from his friend Jake of an old record from 1960 1961 it
was a how to record,
how to handle and how to honor the American flag because of the narrator,
but the first hundred 50 years,
there were no rules for the flag to correct this situation.
In 1923 the representatives of 68 patriotic and civic organizations met in
Washington d c he insists that we follow the flight from the left to the rack.
No, no. It must be from the right to the left.
She drove off the national code of flag etiquette.
According to the law, our flag should always be raised briskly faster.
It's only faster, Andrew, the very peak of the statutes
when the flag is displayed over the middle of the street,
it should be suspended vertically with the union to the north. Yeah, on an east.
West street, excuse me,
or to the east on a north South Street does this treatment east where I think it
runs east west, but east west Westerns. I run north,
south and side. Been a kid. Mark. Yes.
D I got the American flag,
the police regimented a flag and I got eight thumbtacks. Now what should I do?
You put up both of them, man, they, but you've got to listen to them. The man,
the flag may be displayed against a wall crossed with another flag in this
arrangement. However,
the flag of the United States should always be on the left with its staff in
front of the staff of the other flag lightly before being lowered at sunset.
The flag should again be raised to the peak momentarily.
It should be lowered slowly with a solemn dignity be fitting the occasion.
Why slow down mom?
[inaudible] that's not with the Miami shooting. I say North Sattler.
I drop my phone. You
have a compass mom.
[inaudible]
so there you have it.
Thank you. Now
we sent it off to IRA. Ira opened it up or whatever.
Put It on it and this is his opinion.
It was horrible. Yeah, it was really hard.
When you say I do it to the point where like we're like, you know, there's,
there's, there's stories which, which people turn in and, and you know,
then they need a little buffing up here and there and then there's stories that
are bad and then there's a special category where we really don't know what to
say.
So apparently he didn't like it. Uh, here's what his producer,
Julie Snyder had said.
And I remember at the time I was working out of my apartment and so I remember
even at one point standing in the bathroom staring at that brick wall listening
to the piece while I was on the phone and just being really, really confused.
I thought it was past this,
but I'm literally tearing up in embarrassment right now.
I was just very confused. I was very, very, very confused.
I have a better perspective on it now. I stand by my earlier job.
I am not confused and, and everything that was bad about it, it's still bad.
Like it, it doesn't have a point. You know what I mean?
Like it starts off in a place that, that, that,
that seems like it could go somewhere and then it's almost like the two of you
take this premise of this old record and then you just kind of dance on the
surface of this record and thrown a lot of shenanigans and then it ends and it
says literally nothing. So at the end of two minutes,
it's both sort of complicated.
You keep waiting to understand what is it about and then ultimately you are left
wondering what was that about? I mean, I mean,
it's just amazing that you were able to,
to put together such a wonderful program after that. I, I, you know, that,
that somehow, I mean, I don't,
I'm trying to say that that was listening back to it today. I was just like,
wow, it is really interesting to see sort of the incredibly early stages.
You just got really, really headed in the wrong direction.
But if someone were to have walked in the room and asked both of you,
will these two guys succeed at Vac at that moment you would have said no
freaking [inaudible].
Oh, absolutely not. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. A community.
They're terrible influence on each other.
That jad allows a kind of stuff indulgence in Robert and Robert brings out a
sort of self indulgence and Jad clearly looked terrible chemistry.
Like I'd never, I'd never would've put you together on anything ever again.
[inaudible] let
me just say like, this wasn't an episode where, where we were,
we were demanding a lot. We were looking, all we wanted was,
things would be short. And if this is an episode where one of the,
one of the segments that made it where you guys didn't with simply scallops on a
beach, no narration, just going like click the cook, Cook, Cook, Cook, Cook,
Cook, Cook. That's it. The sound,
the scallops for 25 seconds we ran that instead of running this.
So we lost out the scallops.
Yeah. Well first of all, IRA went to Brown University.
They don't know anything there. They don't have majors. They don't have any,
I don't know what they do there exactly.
But if that man thinks that clicking scallops beats our flag thing,
he should go back to radio school and start all over. It's my opinion,
my humble opinion. Yes,
exactly. Got a little Oberlin. Yeah. Ah,
anyway, no, he's a great supporter of the show.
So this was an in auspicious beginning to say say the least. We thought,
well if we get,
if we failed on the two minute IRA thing like with now what are we going to do?
So uh,
what your friend is in this situation is that there is a kind of a restless
newness and a kind of ambition that sort of,
and I really do feel it comes from here in some way that you,
you keep wanting to poke at things, you keep wanting to challenge things.
The flip side of that as the IRA situation was,
which just one bit of evidence of four is that sometimes it doesn't translate so
well to the rest of the world. Yeah. I go by her. Yeah.
Recently there was somebody who was a vomiting in color this week on campus.
Like you know,
that's a little excessive either to taking color dye and then vomiting out in
some kind of interesting tablet here though.
Well, well I'll just give you an example. Personally,
I spent four years, uh, and composition here, writing music,
uh, writing this kind of music basically.
What were you thinking? I was thinking 200 years of,
you know, European harmony handed down that, you know, screw that.
Why should we take the harmonies that are given to us from the European
[inaudible] what's that?
[inaudible] what does that ideal continent doesn't enter the new confidence
question, man. Question
in did you makes perfect sense here.
It overlap.
[inaudible] is the only room where you'd get applause for that kind of music.
And I love you all for it. But no, no quicker.
Could you clear a room then it put something like
on and people would just run from the room. And I've tried this in New York.
I've said, hey, check this thing out. I made when I was a senior and uh,
it didn't go so well. Um, for me,
Oberlin and the kind of uh,
thought process and respect for ideas and also hostility towards ideas that you
want to sort of, you want to poke at things that, oh,
very Oberlin's spirit is something that for me was like a grenade where you pull
the pin and it goes off later.
And for me that was about seven years later.
I mean I spent several years wondering what the hell did I learn here?
Like I know how to create some of the most awful and dissonant music to saw
pianos in half, which was like encouraged and odd ways.
Not that I ever did that, but what does that really give you?
But what it gives you,
I think is something interesting and beautiful because those ideas come back in
a very different form.
So you can see then that really what we're doing is,
this is about complex ideas,
but it is essentially because of Janet is a big musical composition that we are
doing.
This gives us a chance to do what music actually does when it's just naked and
being music,
which is to thrill you or give you a feeling of deep sadness or grief.
Sure.
[inaudible]
so anyways,
we went on and on and around who was where the overland nostalgia began.
So we'll leave it at that for now. But afterwards we had time for two questions.
The audience questions weren't recorded so Robert had to paraphrase. Here he is.
The question is how do we choose what level to approach a topic at when our
listeners range from people who know nothing to people who know all too much.
Um, that's an interesting question cause it is maybe uh, Robert and I are very,
uh, we like each other a lot. Um, but we this, we disagree on many,
many things and this is the one of the ones we always fight about cause I come
down on the, on one side of your question and he comes down on another often.
I am a network trained reporter in my companies where I've worked at ABC for
example, if you have a problem,
like if you go jack and Jill went up the hill to fetch,
I'm not sure exactly what kind of a substance it was.
I then dropped the substance, make it a pale. He's going to just fetch a pail.
The Jack and Jill went up the hill to fetch a pail. Good.
We don't have to deal with a water issue at all. It also shortens the peace.
So I,
I find safety in less and what I discovered is he thinks,
he thinks to say to solve it is to say Jack and Jill went up the hill to get a
pail of, well first of all, we'll begin with two molecules.
We'll put them together. Then we'll add another molecule in quarter.
Let's talk to 17 people about that. So no, we do not do that.
So we have it.
We have a complexity disagreement that sort of runs through these shows where
I'll come in with a 25 minute version of some sort of neuroscience story with,
with very exciting words like dorsolateral prefrontal cortex over and over.
And he's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. What's had to say that him is like terrifying to me.
I think if you have a latinate you just run from the room. That's what I think.
So we have a,
a bit of a tug of war often during the editing process where where I put in too
much, he takes out and then we sort of like, we find a nice balance where we,
we might be talking to, I don't know everybody,
but talking in a way that doesn't fall into the traps of talking to those who
know too much but also doesn't dumb down.
So there is a broad expansive geography in the middle. I think we both
start also is very [inaudible].
We don't really know what we're talking about at the beginning.
And then we find out along the way and we make that very clear.
So we never pretend anybody that we're scholars because we're not.
And we do represent ourselves as novices, which is a good thing.
It is a good thing in a couple of ways. First it means we can say what honestly.
And the second thing it's like, could you explain that again? Honestly.
And then the third thing is it, um,
it allows us to challenge these people,
uh, as though we were ordinary. Curious folks say,
you can't mean that we have a show coming up right now about synthetic biology
where engineers are building life forms that are new to existence,
new to the history of life, and they're doing it quite aggressively.
And, uh,
we know we yell at them and we fight with them and we argue with them and I give
right back.
But we're trying to model a kind of conversation with important people,
powerful people, but particularly knowledgeable people where we say,
you can go up to a person with a lot of knowledge and ask him why.
Ask him, how does he know that? Tell him,
stop asking him why he keeps going and get away with it.
And that's important. Yep.
Also for me, I mean, just to add to that, uh, it's important to me. I mean,
I am the child of two scientists and uh, it's funny,
I once tried to interview my mom and she went into scientist mode and it was
really startling because she would,
I mean my whole life would come home at the dinner table and she's studying
intake of fat into cells. That's her thing. And so she'd say,
here's how I think it works. Jan.
She grabbed a Napkin and like kinda carve it into a circle, like a cell and say,
here's, okay, now this salt shaker, this is a, this is a fat molecule.
It's trying to get into the cell and it's coming, coming, coming, coming,
coming. But it needs something to ferry it through the cell wall.
So here's the fork. The fork is a protein. It's a protein I study in,
it takes the salt shaker, which is the fat,
and it ferries it through the cell wall and she's just like,
I don't know what the hell she's talking about, but,
but what I get from her is this, like excitement. It's a passion. It's a just,
it's a sense of mystery of like figuring something out about the universe.
But then I tried to interview her and she went into a really sort of careful
mediated scientist way.
We're using like Alpha lipoic acid, kind of chronic really big words.
And so for me it's about challenging people and it's about challenging people
who know as he was saying.
But it's also about presenting science as something which is not inevitable.
It is not something where people who are esteemed sit behind podiums and convey
knowledge to the rest of us who know nothing. It's about going into your lab,
screwing up, making mistakes, you know, breaking stuff,
doing it again and again and again till you get lucky. You know, it's just,
it's like anything, it's like, it's like a board.
Like you have to get lucky a lot of times. Yeah. So it's a, so for me, I, I,
there's a double edge to this. Like you want, you don't,
you want to bring them off their podium.
You also want to make them feel a flawed and wonderful,
you know? [inaudible]
well, we'll, we'll take one last question. If you got me. Yeah.
How do we pick what to talk about? Well, I don't [inaudible]
no, exactly. I W we live,
we talk about a lot of things and then something stick to the wall.
Like we were talking about sperm.
We're not sure where we're allowed to talk about sperm in public, but uh,
sperm has gotten so interesting. Did you know recently in the last few weeks,
did you know that the testes have a blue whale that can weigh one ton?
I mean that just stops the traffic.
So we have to sing that whether we're allowed to,
whether we're allowed to do that.
So sometimes we have to like sort of test whether it's polite enough.
But the other thing is is do we continue to think about it? Does it Sorta,
does it stay sticky? And if we keep coming back, I'm sorry.
Hey, you're the school where they're vomiting for art out there. Uh,
so thank you all very, very much for coming. It's been a, a great,
great delight to be here. Thanks
you enjoyed the podcast.
Thanks to everyone at Oberlin College for the warm homecoming reception
radio labs funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
I'm jabbing rod for Robert Krulwich and I take care.